all right hello
you know it's really hard to say not say
good morning as everybody is coming in
since it is morning my time zone but
good morning good day good afternoon
good evening to all of you wherever you
may be joining us from we are so excited
to have you here with us and investing
time into yourself your family your pets
your communities by gaining knowledge
that you can then spread and share with
others so welcome to
ask that live
my name is Rebecca dukes and I am very
honored to be your host of this program
we bring information to you each and
every week every Friday and if you're
watching the replay we're so glad that
you found us because it's through these
replays that we're able to re reach more
and more people
with information they may not find
anywhere else and this information is to
empower you you know so many times we
can become so dependent on something or
someone else and folks it's time to take
our health into our own hands who has a
better interest than yourself
well I guess if somebody's wanting to
fill their pockets but hey we're
empowering you with information that you
can do on your own
to improve your health journey and today
we are focused on your pet's Health
Journey so these can be small pets birds
cats dogs rabbits cows let's go bigger
and horses and even rhinoceroses
so I love the fact that the doctor that
we have with us today has even
done some remarkable
it not so much research because we think
of animals and research but actually
finding
things within
our animal species
and we're talking like 550 or 451
different species
finding things that are causing poor
health or death
all right so we're not researching to
see if some type of chemical is going to
affect an animal and then eventually
affect a human no that is not what we
are about we are about building
sustaining
regaining maintaining whatever words you
want to use at whatever stage that you
or your pet is at we are here to give
information that helps to protect life
we're not looking to cause any type of
damage to life and that's one thing that
I really respect about the doctor that
we have with us is you know that
Hippocratic oath to do no harm
he takes it very seriously very
seriously and has dedicated his life to
figuring out what is causing harm so
that we can stop and correct and prevent
all of those things
but
the FDA requires me to let you know that
our products are not meant to take the
place of your primary care physician and
they are not meant to prevent cure any
type of diseases but from personal
experience and experience of many of the
people on this call including my
co-hosts Ruth Ellen Sanchez nasima Omar
John T mccallier Heather Bowen and Dr
Judy
we have living
proof can we say proof jonty
testimony results
all of these things that we've
experienced firsthand
in having confidence to be here today to
share them with you
so without further ado
it is my privilege and honor to present
to you
I think the most outstanding
veterinarian alive and over the at least
the last 50 years
who has been very very instrumental in
finding the science of epigenetics his
first
research paper
actually was what started him
yep he's got that he's got that book
hold or not so the book epigenetics
um but his first research paper got him
noticed by Merlin Perkins of mutual
Omaha's Wild Kingdom Merlin used or
Marlin sorry I don't know why I keep
saying that wrong doc Marlon Perkins he
used your first paper when you were just
a kid while everybody else was on
Christmas vacation
um where you found
how nitrates affects the thyroid
and those are nitrates that
were in the soil that were being used in
the crops around yeah it was part of the
fertilizer the surrounding uh crops yeah
yeah so you know with that Dr Wall like
that
an amazing journey
on helping Humanity
starting with our animals and today
we're focused on animals so welcome Dr
Wallach and welcome everybody to ask
that live so today we're going to be
focusing on your animal questions so if
you have questions in regards to a pet
make sure that you get your hand up
early because we would love to be able
to get all of our pet questions answered
I do have several emails that we're
going to be going through
um
but Dr Wallach
I think that protecting our pets
and creating an environment that is
protecting them low toxic
because I'd like you to share a little
bit about what toxins will do
to an animal and ourselves included
whenever there's toxins in the
environment so Dr Wallach welcome to ask
that live thank you Rebecca and thank
you team for being here uh just a couple
of minutes to kind of finish to the
introduction
um
yeah let's see here
um it was uh 1963.
okay I was a junior in veterinary school
and I was working my way through
veterinary school I didn't have enough
money to pay for all the tuition and
books and everything uh so
um I was working in the Pathology
Department it was Christmas holiday
1963 and all the professors were gone
and I was you know doing my job in the
Pathology Department and this farmer
comes by and he dumps 50 dead Lambs on
me and the day before
um he had 500 alive six-month-old Lambs
ready to go to market they were going to
go to market right after Christmas and
they're jumping in and out of the the
feed boxes or chasing each other around
laughing and playing like you know 500
Lambs would do and he woke up that
morning you better have to feed him
again they all died they had all died
the night before and
500 had died he brought me 50 of them
and as you point out
um I tracked it down to the nitrates
that were in the surrounding Farms
fertilizers which for six months have
been seeping into the ponds where they
where the lands were getting their water
and in Central Missouri during the
winter time it could be 35 40 50 degrees
they've been running 35 40 50 degrees
well the night they all died the
temperature dropped to 16 and they died
of all of them died of hypothermia
because their thyroids are dead you know
I'm just a kid I'm only 23 years old
and
and so I entitled the paper uh let's see
here hypothyroidism and feeder Lambs
that's kind of a vanilla title
hypothyroidism and feeder Lambs but I
got it published in a Veterinary Journal
okay an international Veterinary Journal
very very proud of that and of course at
that point Perkins I was working with
Marlon Perkins from the mutual Mahal
Kingdom show and also the Zoo St Louis
Zoo and he sent me to to South Africa to
work on the White Rhino project and the
purpose was there's only 300 and I don't
know 347 left in South Africa
and um
they wanted me to catch as many as I
could and send them to the big zoos in
the United States and Europe so we at
least have
captive populations as a white rhino
we'll make a long story short in two
years time I had captured over 200 of
them shipped most of them in the United
States a few of them to Europe and he
took my paper that I had given him a
copy of on on the deaths of the 500
sheep and got a 25 million Grant from
NIH to try and find a canary in the mine
the idea was to find a canary in the
mine and the canary in the mine of
course
was going to be zoo animals in the big
cities and if they would die from
pollution we knew to evacuate the cities
we were going to use the zoo animals
like the old coal miners used to use the
canaries down in the mine if the gases
leaking in the mine the canaries would
fall off the perch and die and they knew
to get out so it was a whole purpose of
the thing make long story short in 10
years I did over 20 000 autopsies
seventeen thousand some change of over
450 species of animals
three thousand humans almost three
thousand not quite but almost three
thousand humans and
got all this published and
um it was the end of the project
and so
um to make a long story short I got a a
job at the Yorkies primate Center in
Emory University in Atlanta Georgia
working for NASA and found the first
non-human cases cystic fibrosis thought
to be the big genetic disease uh big
genetic birth defect in humans and I
found out there was just a simple
nutritional efficiency he got it ready
for publication when I turned in the the
sort of my paper that I was going to
present for publication they fired me
because I said well look you're out of
your mind everybody knows That's a
classic example of a genetic
deficiency okay genetic disease not a
nutritional deficiency and so that's a
long story but I went back to school and
became a naturopathic physician because
I knew then
um that the medical doctors really
didn't know what they were talking about
and so that led to me finding the cause
for instance cure of cystic fibrosis the
cause of prevention cure muscular
dystrophy the cause of prevention of
sediment death syndrome you don't hear
about those three
um problems anymore with humans because
um our attorney Jonathan eboard myself
uh we've beat the FDA and and
um federal court nine times at least
that I know of one of them was to get
these nutrients into the baby Farmers
Enfamil Similac that kind of stuff we
did that and so you don't hear about
these disease anymore because they got
these nutrients into the baby formulas
and the only ones you will have or
there's a problem where there's a mother
who's been eating a lot of gluten
doesn't absorb anything doesn't take
vitamins and minerals and gets pregnant
and so the baby can be division
something and and yet
um
um the city of roses or monstrous feet
and of course the doctors are saying
that the babies are dying of cinnamon
death syndrome SIDS because the mothers
are laying on them and suffocating
that's what that was the story of the
day that mothers were laying on their
babies and suffocating them and so many
mothers whose babies had died of Sids
they committed suicide because they're
excommunicated from their churches their
families kicked them out so they were
laying on their babies and suffocating
him of course that wasn't true they were
dying of hypertrophy cardiopathy heart
disease the same thing that kills young
athletes
because of nutritional efficiency in Dr
Milan and I went to China we did 1 700
autopsies on kids and hey Long John
Province um Keyshawn University
published in three languages Mandarin
Cantonese in English
and as showed very clearly that Senate
death syndrome was caused by deficiency
of a single nutrient
so that's that's sort of the lead in
stories
well thank you Dr Wallach for that lead
in and everybody
you can go to
askdoglive.com
and you know I love technology but that
glare on your shiny cover here
that's good you're tilted it perfectly
okay thank you now there is one there is
one other piece my thesis is still today
in the Smithsonian Institute is a
national treasure on those uh um 20 000
autopsies and
um the the book was called the disease
of exotic animals sold WV Saunders a big
medical textbook publisher company sold
them for 25
000 each they published ninety thousand
they sold them in 90 days 25 000 each
and um of course epigenetics only sells
for 25 and it's a summary of that big
expensive thing my thesis is in the
Smithsonian this is the National
Treasure and so we're republishing it
but to keep the expense down each
chapter is going to be a book
so it's going to be a book set and each
chapter is going to be a book so it'll
be cheaper people can buy one chapter at
a time as opposed to the whole book and
everything
and we've added a lot of new stuff to it
because a lot of this happened okay
since
1965 and to to
1975. so a lot has happened since then
and we're going to give the good Lord
all the credit and it's one of those
things where people are going to love
this this set okay and and
um that's one of our five projects I
know you and I have a project you got a
big team going on one of your book
projects so we're excited about that I
don't know if it's going to come out yet
this year early next year but I'm
excited about it though the Wallach uh
let's see here is the Wallach um
there you are the wallet Revolution and
so I'm looking for that that's going to
be very exciting and um uh I know you
put a lot of effort into that and so
that's gonna be a good one
yeah there's there's a lot going on
folks and going back to the reprint of
Dr wallach's thesis and having it
presented in chapters
it's not going to be a thousand dollars
per chapter with 25 chapters
I'm just saying
um so it is being published and and
reprinted in a way that's going to be
affordable for all of us and Dr Wallach
I have had many people
message me and say his original
was 25
000 this should be more than 25 dollars
so folks
um you do want to go to drjwalek.com and
get your copy now because
as as somebody that really finds value
and what Dr Wallach has done and with
the prices of printing going up and we
are looking at doing more printing
because the books have been selling
we're getting low on inventory
the prices will be going up so if you
are interested in any of Dr wallach's
books make sure that you do go to drj
wallick.com where all of his books are
presented there including CDs I'm
excited to be able to announce that in
the near future we will have digital
downloads of his CDs so for those of you
who do not have cd players you will have
access to those
um right after purchase be able to
download those and and listen
and then on askdoc live
dot com we have
many of Dr wallach's most popular books
so feel free to go there also and get
his most popular titles so
Dr Wallach yes ma'am
I just want to remind everybody
that this program is a resource
you have put a lot of time and research
and your heart is going out to make sure
that this information
is being shared so you you basically you
donate your time in all of this you are
not paid to be on our show you are not
paid to be on anybody's zooms or
podcasts or radio programs
you're doing this because you took that
oath of Do no harm very seriously
am I correct you are correct and of
course that's one of the things that uh
I wanted people to realize that when
they're purchasing those books it's um
their investment in themselves and their
family and their Community uh and I
didn't want to well I might be
interested but I don't like to make all
that money so uh even youngevity I do
not have a salary I don't have a
paycheck and although I'm one of the
founders of youngevity I purposely set
it up so I don't get a paycheck from
youngevity
foreign
[Laughter]
another story that I that I heard this
week that just really touched my heart
um but let's go to
making sure people get back with a
person that shared this program with
them
because those people
believed enough in Dr wallach's message
that they wanted to make sure you also
got this information so if you're here
listening with us live or watching a
replay make sure that you get back with
a person that shared this program with
you they have a vested interest in
it's not even a vested interest in
sharing the information but they have a
heart that has the compassion to want to
see
are
culture our generation Our communities
healthier and stronger because face it
folks we are not chemical or
pharmaceutical deficient
it's mineral deficiencies it's toxins in
our environment that epigenetics is the
science of how the things around us and
the things we put in US affect the way
our genes are expressed
so if you've been told that you have a
genetic condition
um find Hope in the fact
that that's that's a skate boat go
because they don't know the cause but Dr
Wallach found the cause and our mission
is to make sure that that gets out
so share this program with anybody and
everybody you can go to askdocklive.com
you're gonna find almost two and a half
years now of programs recorded sharing
this information
so we encourage you to share it share it
share it share it
because that's how we are going to be
able to
make a difference
Dr well
we do have a couple of hands up but
there's a couple there's something this
is ask that live
ask that lie I mean who better to ask
than a veterinarian
that's a pathologist
who saved the white rhinos in South
Africa
who found the canary in the minds that
they
who actually found the cause of the
liver cancer that was going around in
zoos and bears around the world
so let's talk yeah
I mean
I I can't think of a better person to
ask these questions too
but what I would like to focus on Dr
Wallach is
toxins
okay
let me give a two-minute version of that
liver cancer and the bear story that'll
kind of be a good lead one minute okay
one minute okay okay when I when Perkins
got me back from Africa to do that
pathology project okay uh to to find out
what was going on uh he gave me a list
of stuff that he was interested in in
addition to finding you know the purpose
of defining the canary in the mind thing
for pollution for humans in big cities
in Zeus and he says well here's my list
and the first thing on the list was in
every zoo in the world the Bears of
every species were dying you know polar
bears black bears grizzly bears and
brown bears and so on uh Kodiak bears
they're all dying of liver cancer all
over the world so I knew there had to be
some common thread since they're all
over the place different food and blah
blah blah well it turns out in every zoo
in the world they were selling peanuts
to the visitors to throw peanuts at the
Bears because that's how they made their
money because they're Community zoos and
they were free to get in free entrance
so they're making their money by selling
peanuts and the bears learn to stand up
and wave their their paws and the people
would throw peanuts at them well it
turns out that those peanuts had a
uh fungus in them well aspergillus
slavus because they grow in the ground
tree nuts are safe but peanuts grow on
the ground they have they have
aspergillus flavors grown in them they
produce a toxin called aflatoxin which
causes liver cancer and so we stopped
the sale of peanuts in the zoos all over
the world and the liver cancer stopped
liver cancer is caused by amphotoxin now
they're starting to go back to that
because this has been that was a 19
let's see here that was
1965 kind of thing or 1975 excuse me
1975 it was 1975. okay and so was that
25 and 20 is over 50 years ago and saw
the people who know the answer to that
are dead and all these new kids come
along well why aren't we selling peanuts
to throw to the beers and so now the
liver cancer is coming back because they
have forgotten the cause of the liver
cancer in the Bears that was an old
story
and so now they're getting back to that
because they're selling peanuts again in
the zoos
well and you think about it Dr Wallach
peanuts
they're
I guess I've never grown peanuts myself
I love to Garden but that's why beer
drinkers got liver cancer it wasn't the
alcohol in the beer it was the peanuts
they were eating with their beer
I prefer pretzels and I don't do beer so
I'm gluten alert gluten
I changed my ways I changed my ways and
folks I'm so glad that I did because
since doing that
um I've lost even more weight my skin
looks better
I'm just absolutely loving it Z radical
is one of my best friends absolutely I
love it with an ounce of also the plain
or the strawberry kiwi Cherry mint
um it mixed in there so that I know I'm
getting all the minerals that my body
needs plus extra minerals from the
different Seas
and seaweed and stuff like that in here
yeah so there is there is so much
research that's been done on
fucoiden which is one of the main
ingredients in the Z radical if you go
to pubmed.gov and type in fucoiden
you're going to come up with thousands
of research papers including some that
pertain to The Big C
I guess there's two Big C's right now
but the original Big C and
it's just amazing
what natural ingredients that were
created by the Creator put here on Earth
for us to find and use can do within the
body and Dr while like you're one of
those founders of what those natural
ingredients and elements
can do within the body but it's not just
one it's not just two it's 90.
and it's correct 16 minerals 16 vitamins
12 minutes and Three fatty acids all
um vertebrates require those 90 cents of
nutrients and then there's secret sauces
to all the various systems you know
there's a reproductive system the immune
system all that kind of stuff that's
different on top of the basic 90.
okay Doctor work well like I want you
mentioned a word that I want you to
explain
because not everybody knows this because
we've got kiddos watching this show also
vertebrates
okay vertebrates
human beings and animals that have
vertebrate spinal columns okay and it
could be an alligator it could be a bear
it could be an elephant could be a human
being could be a monkey it could be a
gorilla uh could be
um a giraffe any vertebrae is
susceptible to all the same problems
when they're nutritiously deficient
either of the 90 are the secret sauces
for the various systems
so with the backbone
yes
bones a backbone everything that stems
off that we need the 90 essential
nutrients
and sauces the secret sauces well and
especially the secret sauces if
there's been decline that's already
started
and in most cases mine included that
decline started
at well before birth so
I love the fact that
you know the things that I was dealing
with when I was a teenager when I was
eight years old I no longer have to deal
with even
so let's go ahead and help others find
that as well
today we're going to focus on pets
Okay so
Christina writes in Dr Wallach and she
um she adopted a female to almost
three-year-old female
border collie Husky Pit mix from the
pound and she went blind within just a
few days
she was trying to figure out you know
what what she had done well she had
gotten some star anise from an online
seller and it is a very strong
very strong odor which but it's natural
but
her dog went blind and took her to the
vet and the vet put her on steroids oral
and topical
um and it took a while for the
inflammation and everything to come down
before the eyesight started coming back
and that this right here folks is why I
am choosing today's topic and that has
to do with creating a low toxic
environment for our pets
and we have to remember even though
something is natural does not mean that
it's non-toxic
and with pets and children we have to be
very cognitive of what even essential
oils we are using
around our pets or not to that yet put
that down put that down I sent Dr
Wallace across get them out of my camera
view please because right now I'm
focused on keeping a clean environment a
non-toxic environment and then we'll add
in those nutrients also I mean you can
do one or the other but you're going to
get the best results when you do both
okay
okay so we have a we have a product line
that we absolutely love and it is called
Nature's direct and it does come in
concentrate form
so see Dr Wallach has a bottle also and
I have this it looks like we have the
same one the super strength cleaner and
this stuff is amazing
where they do have a carpet and
upholstery cleaning specifically for
carpet upholstery I also use this and
when you have a litter of 16 puppies
running around
I would not be without it but this can
be used on the floors on the counters
um spray it you know right in front of
the door where the dog goes in and out
and it's going to help to keep things
cleaner but it's going to do it in a way
with ingredients that are not toxic to
your pet
the commercial cleaners that are on the
market
they include some pretty harsh chemicals
that we don't think about it our pets
are constantly on the ground anything
that's on that surface whether they're
in the house or they're outside in the
yard
pesticides herbicides all of that is
being absorbed into their bodies so
where we can let's be cognitive and
intentional and making sure that we
create a non-toxic and environment
and with pets I know sometimes it can
get a little stinky
so I love the fact that we have the
enviromist
which I think you have on your desk Dr
Wallach you have a little sprayer that
you can just spray and you can use it
around your pets you can use it around
your kids you can use it around yourself
there you go I have one in my car that I
keep especially with you know stinky
active voice I love the fact that I can
just take that and and it doesn't just
cover up that right you just
it doesn't just cover up the smell but
it actually
knocks those those particles out of the
air
um and eliminates them and then
I have my revitalizer
and I can run that throughout the day
cleans the air especially during times
where there's a lot of different nasties
running around in the air
um
wonderful for if you have a small
business an office but I use
our formula for children
um
and we have the formulas for adults we
have formulas for children we have one
that is
um amazing with the different
ingredients that are in a very common
formula that is for helping with keeping
the immune system strong
works on keeping viruses and bacterial
things
we're not to that yet Dr Wallach are you
trying to keep me on track or get me off
track
but anyways we're trying to keep a good
environment good clean environment so as
we're breathing things in we're not
having to
do as much work
to push them out and detoxify the body
because that's where the nutrition comes
in Dr Wallach when you're flooding your
body with nutrition
you're detoxifying you're pushing that
bad stuff out right that's correct your
body will do its job and your body has
two things to bring the good stuff in
and Rehab everything and get rid of the
bad stuff
and isn't it easier to eliminate as much
bad stuff as possible so that we don't
have so much to eliminate because I know
detox
stinks I'm going to use the stink word
instead of the other word because
detoxing the body is not always Pleasant
I mean it's like flu-like symptoms
and for some people it's times 10. so
it goes for our pets also
you know bad stuff does not smell good
that's that's for sure that's for sure
so okay so now let's get to
where do you find this stuff you can go
to ask Dock Live we have them there on
our website
um click on store but most importantly
if you were referred by somebody
specific get back with them and say Hey
I want some of those low toxic non-toxic
cleaners for myself and my pets
so that we can create a non-toxic
environment and they're reusable
the little bottles are recyclable you
use this much
and in this much I have I think six
six refills on my big bottle
and I'm not paying for water
so I love that
and it smells good and it makes
everything nice and clean and fresh and
you don't even have to scrub as much
because of the the natural solvents that
are in it I just Jeanette and she's part
of the team that put these products
together is just brilliant absolutely
brilliant and they're created in
Australia Dr Wallach
you have a little fondness for Australia
especially their Australian seasoning
salt
so oh that's right you have that on your
desk too there you go seasoned salt
has yeah salt causes heavily
pressure no no no no
doctors cause heavily pressure
and what else do they cause that's
linked to Salt sodium or chloride
okay they've caused all kinds of
digestive problems okay because
um your stomach acid requires salt to
make stomach acid stomach acid
hydrochloric acid and sodium chloride is
the raw material the chief cells in your
stomach need to make stomach acid if you
want digestive issues eat gluten and
avoid salt you will have digestive
problems
and so what is salt Dr Wallach it's a
mineral it's it's two minerals sodium
and chloride it makes up the majority of
the minerals in the oceans and the Gulfs
and all these sea salt water stuff and
that was the first supplement ever sold
thousands of years ago people along the
coast would boil salt water and get the
sea salt and the sea salt had
like 17 minerals in it or something like
that including
um one that was good for the thyroid
gland okay
you know the one for the thyroid gland
which one is that
the thyroid gland is right here it's
like a butterfly
mineral
iodine all right there you go and so
they were selling iodine thousands of
years ago and people would have goiter
and they would take the sea salt and
their glider would go away thousands of
years ago now they didn't know it was
they didn't know it was the iodine but
they knew there was something to do with
the sea salt
okay they got rid of their goiter and so
this was the first nutritional
supplement program
um well I should say the second the
first one was just salt
okay just salt and because Inland they
didn't have access to Salt so they had
to make it on the coast and bring it in
you know on
um wagons being pulled by horses or uh
and saddlebags or on some guy's backpack
he's walking in Inland or something like
that we're talking thousands of years
ago that um
boiling salt water was the was a big
thing because that's where everybody got
there's stuff whatever it was they
didn't know what it was but they knew
that it was helpful for the thyroid and
it was just actually that mysterious
mineral called iodine okay and of course
even though my 500 sheep had died in one
night from hypothermia even though they
had thyroid glands and they were
probably getting iodine but they were
getting their nitrates the nitrates in
the drinking water subdue the function
of the thyroid gland and so when the
temperature dropped they couldn't
maintain their body temperatures and
they all died a hypothermia in one night
so Dr Wallach share with us what is a
symptom of goiter
well you get a big knot on your throat
uh you're tired all the time okay your
immune system is low you're susceptible
to all kinds of infections and diseases
and debilitating degenerative diseases
and so on
and that's it I mean that's that's a lot
and so you can't work you can't function
you can't communicate and you just want
to lay around and sleep all the time and
you know back when everybody had to work
their way
physically on the farm and the ranch on
the fishing boat whatever it was if you
couldn't function you know you didn't
eat because they just kicked you in the
barn and you just stay there until
either you died or you recovered and so
once they learned that sea salt
solved a lot of those problems
that goiter went away which is very
visible big big knot on the throat the
glider would go away and their energy
would come back so they all love sea
salt as a result it was it was the the
um
it was just the nutrients in the sea
salt
and I've seen that on animals too Dr
Wallach it's not a human issue it's like
the feeder 500 sheep died of goiter
because the iodine couldn't keep up with
all the nitrates in the drinking water
foreign so you keep that in mind folks
the things that are going on around you
are also affecting your pets
so if you've got some things some
nutritional deficiencies
that are causing different symptoms
make sure that you
take that into consideration for your
pets too even if you're not feeding them
table food
are you intentional on giving them what
Dr Wallach is give holding up right now
arthroducts the arthrodex and the arthro
decks are good for cats dogs Birds
um
rabbits rabbits yeah that's going to
include the the 60 minerals that Dr
Wallach found to be essential essential
meaning we do not make them and they are
required for
a life that thrives
one thing since you said talk about
longevity
prior to the Advent of complete dog
foods average lifespan of a pet dog was
just a two two to three years
put the Arthur decks down it's hiding
your face oh there you go
thank you yeah and
um the
um which they say two to four years is
all you got once they came out was the
complete dog foods with all the 90
essential nutrients in them in 1900 dogs
began to live to be 12 15 years old
so they tripled their lifespans just by
adding the vitamins and minerals to the
dog for commercial dog food when they
were getting
table straps they were dying at two to
three to four years of age now there's a
clue
yeah
and their humans were sick too Dr
Wallach so
yeah and then here we have we always
like to give treats I mean we give our
kids treats we give our pets treats why
not give them a treat that is full of
nutrition as well
and that's with for for the dogs we have
the bark bites
um we even have a a hemp line a CBD line
for our pets as well
um and again you can find those on asked
by
so let's go to the first hand that is up
Dr Wallach
um and
I'm not sure if this is going to be a
person question or a animal question but
let's
now this is kind of weird because on the
top it has one person first and then on
my list it has another person first
um but we're gonna go ahead and go with
the list and that's Rosemary
Rosemary
go ahead and unmute yourself hold on
shoot I hit the wrong button Dr Wallach
oh
did we say bye bye to Rosemary no but
now I can say please unmute Rosemary
you're on live with Dr Wallach well I'm
sorry but it is a human question well
let's go for the humans too we love
humans uh a few uh sometime back I got
my scalp turned bright red and then got
flaky and a lot of dandruff like stuff
and now it is sliding down my forehead
and my forehead is very very tender and
it now it's in my eye
[Music]
have you any help for me on this what
that might be sure how old are you I'm
76 I weigh 130 pounds five seven okay
now do you have any tinnitus or ringing
your ears no
how many times a night do you wake up to
urinate once three times five times
three four times
okay
um do you have any arthritis or joint
problems or back problems knee problems
hip problems
um I have one thumb that's giving me an
issue no no I'm talking about you yes
yes you do
so so you have joint problems you have
do you have balance problems any vertigo
dizziness or our balance problems I used
to but I've been on the uh
osteofx and that's got gone away okay
good now let's see here
um Rebecca what do you think is going on
here she's waking up three four times a
night to urinate she's had all this
stuff going on with her skin and her
scalp and her forehead she lost her
vision but it came back when she got on
some supplements what's going on
well she definitely has still has
osteoporosis of the skull Dr Wallach but
it went for the skin condition my
question to her is I know you mentioned
taking the Osteo effects are you also
taking the efas the essential fatty
acids yes I take efas and also
um Hair Skin and Nails okay and are you
gluten-free
yes
okay what about everybody else in the
house is everybody in the house
including the dog the cat well I'm I'm a
massage therapist and my clients are not
gluten-free oh so you're getting
cross-contaminated that's the problem
yes yeah and so you're getting some
gluten and that's why you're having an
issue you need to wear gloves and you
need to wear a mask when you're dealing
with these people and don't wash your
clothes that you work with your
Appliance with in the same place that
you wash your clothes that you stay in
the house you're you're you have to have
two different washing machines and
dryers
one for your clinic close
and one for your house clothes okay yes
and then you know
um your body weight uh let's see here
what would you recommend how many uh
Health brain and heart attacks should
she be taking a month
well she's only 130 pounds so I think
she can go away with one or get away
if you want grain and heart
pack okay and then how many bottles of
MSM should she have for collagen for
bones including the skull and joints and
back and everything
yeah so the MSM Ultra you've got enough
for three twice a day and one bottle at
130 pounds do you think that's enough
yep and then how much in the way of
collagen peptides
I would go with two canisters so that
she can get
I'm doing all of that twice a day I do
the MSM twice a day uh three times a day
if I think about it okay if you're doing
all of that and still having problems
that means that you're really seriously
getting cross-contaminated so you need
to wear your mask you need to wear
separate clothes gloves all that kind of
stuff and then you know you may want to
strip down in the front yard put up a
little get a little trailer with a
shower in it and do all that stuff
outside before you go in the house
Dr Wallach I have one more
recommendation for her okay and that's
give a revitalizer
that cleans the air that'll clean the
particles out of the air and how you can
take it Revitalize your wither it's not
that big
yeah it's not very big
um and that'll help keep some of those
contaminants out of the space that
you're working
and I've never had I've never had this
skin issue before and it's really
irritating
and it's also kind of ugly
have you changed your shampoos or
anything like that lately
I changed my shampoo when this first
started but it didn't help
have you have you tried the shampoo and
conditioner from youngevity no three we
have three different options there and I
absolutely love the Organics line
okay
finances are an issue
yeah
um
we have we have some ways to help with
that so make sure that you get back with
the person that
um is your distributor I'm a distributor
oh well then use the contact us on
askdoclive.com and I can share some
helpful hints for you okay thank you
you're very welcome
all right Rosemary thank you so much for
your question
um Dr Wallach let's go ahead and Mark
has a question here he says how do you
swallow the ultra MSM pill it is too
large for me to swallow
well that's easy just break it up smash
between two spoons and putting in a
tablespoon of applesauce
and put in a tablespoon of applesauce so
Mark I hope that helps
um
with getting the MSM that you need the
ultra MSM because our MSM is not like
any other MSM
MSM is actually
um
there we go we had somebody unmuted
um so MSM actually has cofactors what do
co-factors do Dr Wallach
well cofactors are kind of like vitamin
D3 you can take all the calcium in the
world you want but if you're not getting
vitamin D3 to take that calcium and put
it into your bones uh you don't you
don't have anything going on so and I
like to call them secret sauces uh
everybody all vertebrates we already
discussed the vertebrae thing all
vertebrates including humans require
that 90 cents a nutrients 60 minerals 16
vitamins 12 minutes of Three fatty acids
and the only way you're going to
guarantee you're going to get them all
is to take them okay nutritional
minerals are not occur in a uniform
blank around the crust they occur in
veins like gold and silver because in
264 1936 says there's no longer
sufficient minerals in American cell
form cell to support human life so you
have to supplement
can you say that document one more time
slower okay you have Senate document 264
okay thank you okay and then
um then we have the secret sauces you
know we're talking about iodine for the
thyroid
um also for blood pressure issues
um which may be involved in some of the
skin things that people get secondary to
gluten and they may want to take the
ultimate daily classic tablets take
three of those twice a day for 100
pounds of body weight and they will
support healthy blood flows through
blocked arteries uh in this in the brain
the heart the kidneys and get rid of
pressure and so forth and so there's all
kinds of stuff we have for all of these
issues but they're they're part of the
secret sauces which means you need more
of them or there's in some cases they're
not an essential nutrient of the 90 but
they aren't essential nutrient as a
secret sauce okay if you do have a
health stones
all right thank you so much for
clarification on that let's go to our
next town that is up Dr Wallach and
folks if you're on live with us and you
have a question for Dr Wallach go to
that Zoom menu and look for the raised
hand option depending on the device and
the version of Zoom that you have it
might be found under reactions so Rhonda
go ahead and unmute you are on live with
Dr Wallach
hi Rhonda hi Dr Wallach
I'm trying to get my camera on one
second
okay hello hi
how can we help you
uh I have a question about a dog
and it's a genetic problem we're told
so
um
we have a well my daughter-in-law has a
many American Shepherd
and she's a couple years old she just
had a batch of puppies
um but they learned after they got her
that she has this genetic
condition referred to as h-u-u
she has two two copies of it it creates
kidney stones in dogs Okay and she also
is not able to control urinating very
well like she'll go
just randomly in the house even though
she's let outside frequently so she's
having urinary problems and they've been
told it's genetic
okay stop there there are no genetic
diseases
okay that's my thesis is in the
Smithsonian Institute as a National
Treasure tell the veterans I love your
message tell the veterinarian to
um get the book
um
let's see here
um epigenetics the death of the genetic
theory of disease transmission
and so there aren't no Jake Lee
Transmissions that's that's not true
and then when you have elevated
um blood calcium you have kidney stones
and all that kind of stuff that says
that the parathyroid glands are pulling
the calcium out of the bones to try and
get more calcium into the bones because
there's a Calcium deficiency and so what
I'd recommend is that you get the book
Rare Earth of in cures get the book rare
Earthman cures go to chapter 10 11 page
272. and it'll tell you how to collect
the hair off the dog
where to ship it don't forget to put the
check in there because they won't run
the test
without the um check and we'll find out
what what the level the nutritional
minerals are it may show the calcium is
off the chart
well that's not because the dog's eating
too much calcium it's because the
parathyroid glands are pulling the
calcium out of the bones because the
gland perceives that there's a
deficiency okay and it's trying to
rebuild the bones and that's why there's
kidney stones okay and so it's not a
genetic thing it's actually
um you kind of read the dog food label
is there gluten in the dog food you know
wheat Brown oats that sort of stuff any
buckwheat anything like that in in there
um uh is it based is the dog food a dry
dog food based on wheat or oats
uh barley or rye all that stuff's got to
go
okay
of course
again we do have for that dog
arthrodex
and get a good grade of canned dog food
not dry dog food a good grade of canned
dog food that doesn't have any gluten in
it and then add the arthrodex to that
dog food based on the the body weight of
the dog and the label will tell you that
and um it'll all be resolved
it's not a genetic thing
I have a question
um whenever there's an accumulation of
uric acid because it's not dissolving in
the urine and accumulates is that caused
by the same thing
um well uric acid has to do with several
other things possibly could the dog
could have osteoporosis of the skull
okay squeezing the tenth Crown nerve
which caused that sort of stuff problems
okay and so you have to read the labels
on the dog food make sure there's no
gluten in it gluten is a very common
um part of dry dog food
all right they put oats and wheat and
barley and Rye in there corn all kind of
stuff
peanuts
buckwheat all those things are bad
and so going to be very choosy on what
um dog food use I like the canned dog
food because you can put the arthrodex
in there
and it mixes very well okay this is one
of my favorite pet supplements is orange
decks it's one scoop for 20 pounds of
body weight one scoop for 20 pounds of
body weight and that includes canaries
and uh rabbits and wombats and
guinea pigs and rats and and so on okay
okay and um
do you have a recommendation for a dog
food brand well any good brand of dog
food that's canned okay but read the
label and make sure there's no gluten in
it
okay if if you know the prices go too
high for food
um here in the United States and the
markets are cracking because they can't
sell food
I'm going to canned dog food arthrodex
okay
and um you'll be amazed at how well
you'll do arthrodex and canned dog food
no gluten no gluten no gluten
no carbonated drinks even even the diet
one's got to go because carbonation even
in diet drinks neutralizes stomach acid
so you cannot absorb minerals or Digest
food
well thank you so much for your show
y'all uh last week's show was
smoking and you're doing some phenomenal
work
some outstanding work in the Natural
Health Care and healing field and
Rebecca's testimony of Rejuvenation and
healing is
just phenomenal I get so excited on
these calls and I'm hoping soon to be a
bigger presence in my own Community with
your message well thank you maybe you
know you could take it are you an
associate are you a customer only or
I'm a distributor but I haven't really
gotten as active near as much as I would
like to with the business but I've been
learning a lot the last couple years and
so there is a lot to learn with
youngevity but it's such it's just such
a huge blessing as a company it's a
phenomenal huge resource of so many
wonderful things so I'm just excited I'm
hoping in the new year to launch a local
presence here in my community where no
one knows anything about youngevity
and and I hope really to grow the
business for your message okay well
thank you for helping People's Health
and I just don't forget the prices of
books are going up as we're printing new
ones because the printing is more
expensive now so you want to be buying
your books and CDs and DVDs and stuff
like that now okay get the cheaper price
heads up
thank you I have my list I hope to be
ordering very soon I can't wait to read
your books
thank you so much you're you're amazing
and well you're very this is a great
this is a great blessing for the for
everyone thank you
thank you Rhonda appreciate you
you're a rock star
YouTube
now Dr Relic here's a question and this
I think this is a prime time because I
have gotten this question a lot this
week and this Seema just said it's we
need to ask the question and Mark just
said something about it also recently
you have added buckwheat to the list yes
so no wheat barley Rye oats or buckwheat
share with us why you have added
buckwheat okay well buckwheat has about
75 different substances in it
and it's an old standby goes back
forever into especially in Europe and
Africa and so forth in South South
America and so on but it has about five
or seven of those 75 substances
that act exactly like gluten
they're not gluten so when they put on
the label gluten-free buckwheat that's
absolutely true but they have substances
in there that act like
gluten and they destroy
the lining of your intestine your small
intestines should look like a shag rug
it should have these Villi sticking up
which increase your absorptive surface
in your intestines by like 95 percent
well when you you either get gluten or
the substances that are in buckwheat
those Villi go away and there's a lot of
people who say yeah I can't take
buckwheat I really get bad stomach
cramps and diarrhea and okay well those
are the people who are sensitive to this
gluten-like substance in buckwheat so
I'm digging deeper into it there's no
doubt about it that there's many many
people who have a biological problem
with some of those substances in
buckwheat so we've added it to it
because it's just it's as predictable as
gravity and so we do have to alert
people even though it says gluten-free
on the label if you're one of those
people that gets a belly ache or
diarrhea or a lot of gas or something
like that when you eat buckwheat don't
eat buckwheat because you're going to
get the same reaction you do is eating
gluten
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
for that explanation and it is the top
of the hour so let's go ahead and take a
break
um everybody you are tuned in to
askdoc live but today is ask vetlive so
we're going to be talking about pets as
we have been answering those questions
and also of course
as humans you know we're the pets pet
depending on how you want to look at it
or somebody
um so we're going to be doing uh human
questions too as they come up because
were all important but we will be right
back after this short break visit our
website
askdoclive.com or ask jonty do we have
askvetlive.com too I think we do
um and you're going to find more
information in regards to
products The Good Foods bad foods list
Dr wallach's books so much information
that we share make sure that you get
plugged into our newsletter as well and
remember if you were shared this program
by somebody specific get back with them
if you are wanting to get any of the
products that are mentioned on this
program
again my name is Rebecca dukes and we
will be right back after this short
break
and welcome back I hope that you got up
and stretched and moved all around got
all of those fluids in the body moving
and if you are grabbing a drink and you
have some of those plant derived
minerals that Dr Wallach has been uh
promoting for I think 30 maybe 40 years
now
um splash of that in the water
especially when you're a big cup like
this
it's you don't even know that they're
there but you're fortifying your body
with minerals throughout the whole
entire glass and
well for me I get a couple ounces a day
so maybe that's why I am the way I am
um and I'm told that you can't get too
many because of the format that our
plant Drive minerals are they're plant
derived so they're not hard minerals and
they're colloidal suspended in water so
the particles are super tiny where
you're going to get great absorption
that's going into or through the
digestive system which you know starts
in the mouth under the tongue
so I don't even swallow quickly I just
swish it around
drink
throughout the day nice and slow all day
long and make sure that I'm continually
giving my body what it's missing most
because if it's not in the soil
it is not in the food folks plants can
make their own vitamins and
phytonutrients but they cannot make
minerals they have to be in the soil
that they are grown so welcome back Dr
Wallach thank you Rebecca and thank you
you know for the great uh uh information
I really appreciate all the great stuff
you do thank you so very much well I had
a great teacher
[Laughter]
I've been a great student
so
I if if I had no you're a great teacher
now you're a great teacher
it's like a sponge you just soak it all
in and then you have to squeeze it all
out so you can get more in and while
you're squeezing it out
you're empowering others to have that
information also and utilize it and
that's that's just the way I look at it
so I'm honored to be
um the host of ass doc live
and ask that live
and just you know be able to assist you
Dr Wallach and get in the books out
there and
all oh my goodness there's so much going
on folks I'm so excited things we can't
even tell you about yet
um but there's lots of good stuff coming
Dr Wallach is in my opinion
I can't say just getting started because
he has like 14 15 books and over 70
Publications
but the best is yet to come so
we have a question Dr Wallach
or maybe it's a statement so John
um mentions he says I understand that
fructose corn syrup is like gluten now I
heard fructose corn syrup like switches
off your body's ability to feel full so
you're triggered to eat more and more
and more
I personally eliminate corn syrup from
my diet completely and I know that I've
heard Steve mention that your son Steve
wallig
mentioned that the two of you are both
very much not in favor of high fructose
corn syrup
well um
um we're not in favor of any
um manufactured sugars
okay natural sugars you know like eating
an apple the day keeps the doctor away
is fine okay but apple juice is a little
scary
okay because now you're purifying that
sugar okay and so it's one of those
things where
um corn syrup again
um I don't like it because again it's a
manufactured sugar
and so they can put a lot of it uh uh I
believe that's what was in Red Bull as
car as um corn syrup in Red Bull if you
can look that up quickly
I have not looked but I can look yeah
and while I'm looking okay I have to
tell you that um Red Bull one of the
manufacturers one of the original
Founders who turned out to be a
multi-billionaire uh he just died a
little over a week ago at age 78 and so
I began to look at Red Bull which was
the biggest selling energy drink it has
one mineral in it magnesium
it has all the B vitamins it has
some form of sugar
and then it has
um let's see here
carbonated water
and that's it oh caffeine has caffeine
in it
and so this guy who's a
multi-billionaire a wonderful man
donated a lot of money to Great causes
and stuff like that his heart was in the
right place
but he died at 78 because he was
bragging that he had consumed 10 cans of
Red Bull every day for 25 years
and then he woke up dead one morning
okay
yeah so it just says sugars it doesn't
say specifically which sugars but they
did get one thing right Dr Wallach it's
wheat free gluten-free
that's true but I was written shocked
that I only had one meal of magnesium
yeah it's caffeine and magnesium and a B
vitamin
so crazy but
I personally and I can't believe I don't
have mine with me because I usually have
my very no that's not what I was
thinking
I like my rebound and the canister or
my Beyond Tangy Tangerine 2.0 there's
the canister there you go turn her there
we go so I really like that I can adjust
the strength that I want it as far as
sweetness because I'm adding my own
powders in there it has less natural
sugars than they can
um and it doesn't even start with
carbonation so I don't have to worry
about popping atop the day yeah the
canned carbonation in them top the top
the night before you're gonna drink them
these have rebound has 75 minerals in it
is that more than one
yeah that's a little bit more than one
like 74 times
yeah we have 75 minerals and we have of
course the vitamins and amino acids in
there okay and so there's 36 servings in
here a little scoop in there 36 scoop
fulls all right in the boxes I apologize
I don't have a box I'll have to get a
box and put on the on the desk here
um the box has 30 servings and 30 sticks
in the Box the cans come 12 cans in a
case okay and they are carbonated and so
what I do the night before
oh thank you I'm not going to open it
here on the desk I'm just making the
noise okay so I'll pop the tops on two
of them at night time put them in the
refrigerator they off gas the
carbonation at night so in the morning
all the bubblies on their flat if I
drink one with breakfast or at least
half of one with breakfast and depending
on my schedule I'll either drink another
half at lunch time or maybe an hour or
two after lunch okay and so that's how
you do the ones with the with the
carbonation in them okay our our
carbonation the cans but they have the
same formula of nutrients as the
canister
but the canister doesn't have the
carbonation in them stay away from
carbonated water
uh it's just as bad as carbonated even
soft drinks even the diet drinks
carbonation neutralizes stomach acid so
you cannot absorb minerals or digest
food back to you
all right thank you Dr Wallach well
let's go to item a
item a go ahead and unmute yourself
okay all right I have thank you hi I am
not ready for the screen yet and I'm
calling for my sister I hope that's all
right I was just thank you she is uh
just turned 81 she's 5'4 weighs only
about 105 now one or six in there
um the immediate problem is
um just having to get up so many times
during the night to urinate that she's
not getting any sleep okay now are you
talking about five times a night six
times a night ten times a night 20 times
a night it was three to four now she's
on chemotherapy so when she's on the
drip for 48 hours she's having to get up
five times a night
and
why is she on the trip
um calling cancer okay
all right well hope let's keep our
fingers crossed and hope they made a
misdiagnose and let's hope it's only a
gluten issue uh what's going on why is
she getting up so many times at night
Rebecca
well it's those nerves that attach to
the bladder that are being pinched and
squeezed does she see they're laying
flat in a position she doesn't normally
lay in during the day or moving around
well there's another piece to that go
back farther why are those nerves being
pinched well that's osteoporosis of the
skull which is well there you go yeah
and at 81 years old is not uncommon
babies can be born without you
approaches the skull it's not an age
thing but it's common in older people
and 81 years old the odds Arch has
actually approach to the scoliage is
getting up three four five times a night
to urinate and now she's getting up more
often because she's getting IVs and so
um and you say she weighs 105 pounds uh
I would have her get off all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed Meats
no oils no gluten so wheat bread around
my nose no
um no buckwheat no peanuts absolutely uh
no sugar and absolutely no carbonated
drinks any kind even the diet ones and
so what would you give her as a program
Rebecca
well I would definitely start with the
healthy body brain and heart pack
and I would throw in an extra bottle of
selenium Dr Wallach okay
uh three twice a day
and then the MSM Ultra
and remind me the weight again I'm sorry
105.
105. I was thinking it was under 150.
um so one bottle of MSM Ultra so she can
take three tablets twice a day okay
collagen peptides
um and because of having to get up you
know so many times during the night I
definitely go with more so doing the two
canisters per month so she can do one
scoop twice a day and Dr Wallach I love
our collagen peptides because they have
no flavor if you get the plain you can
mix them in cold drinks you can mix them
in warm drinks it does not matter I mix
mine in tea I mix mine in hot cocoa I
mix but in my tangy tangerine and my
rebound
um so I know that I'm getting that extra
collagen that I need and then vitamin D3
Dr Wallach we want to make sure that the
calcium that she's taking in from the
Osteo FX which is in the brain and heart
pack is being absorbed deep into the
bones not just attaching to the surface
very good what did I forget
okay so you know give us a call every
couple of weeks let us know how she's
doing thank you and we can you know
adjust what we need to do here based on
her response okay make sure she's not
eating any gluten no wheat nobody Ryan
notes no buckwheat no peanuts all that's
got to go
all right all right thank you thank you
I told her I'd be calling you thank you
so much okay God bless thank you on Dr
Wallach I want to add one more thing
because we want to make sure that she's
getting good circulation throughout the
whole entire body
and we we can do that by adding in the
ultimate daily classic yeah yeah she
could take three of those twice a day
and that's going to support healthy
let's go through the blocked earners in
the brain the heart the kidneys did you
say she had kidney issues no I didn't
okay what was this product again
ultimate what
ultimate daily classic okay
does she have any blood sugar problems
any diabetes uh not no not that we're
aware of okay did she fall asleep a half
hour to an hour after dinner
um she's not eating uh no no but she's
sleeping all day long
okay well she may have have a glycemia
she may have reactive hypoglycemia and
so uh what would you give her for that
Rebecca
I would recommend getting the sweeties
yeah she could take three of those twice
a day that'll help stabilize blood sugar
and of course with all these nutrients
um including the healthy brand and heart
pack there is iodine in there
um if we had some assurance that she did
have a thyroid issue we'd never take the
ocean's goals through those five today
but there's enough iodine in the
um how the Rain heart pack if he does
have a thyroid issue okay so the Swedish
three twice a day yes ma'am all right
and that'll be that'll be two bottles
item a yeah they're small they're small
bottles so they're yeah so there's
enough in there for two twice a day and
then if you're doing three twice a day
that's gonna be two bottles
okay okay and then you'll have course
you'll have half of it that carries over
to the next month okay
all right thank you item a for caring
for your friend and coming on and asking
um Dr wallet questions on her behalf
let's go to Z and Zia's thank you so
much for raising your hand I
go ahead and unmute yourself because I
see your question that was here in the
chat as well so I'll let you go ahead
and ask ask it awesome hi Dr Wallach hi
Rebecca hi Ruth Ellen
okay so I know um somebody she's 83
years old she's about five four maybe
about 135 pounds she has tremors she was
not diagnosed with Parkinson's but they
did put her on Cinnamon she does not
like drugs at all and she stopped taking
the cinnamon but when I'm with her she
does have the Tremors is there anything
I can recommend for her oh yes okay okay
why don't we start out with you Rebecca
what would you recommend
well we're definitely going to start
with the biggest hammer in the Box Dr
Wallach and that's going to be the
healthy body brain and heart pack and
we're gonna go with the osteoporosis of
the skull protocol which we've given at
least twice already today
because those nerves are being squeezed
hmm okay
okay what would that be go ahead
so that's going to be the MSM Ultra
three twice a day at her weight
uh collagen peptides again two canisters
so that she can get one scoop twice a
day
the vitamin D3
and synaptive one of my favorites
yes so two bottles of synaptive even
though she's only 135 pounds
um I definitely we
Dr Wallach I think I would recommend two
twice a day
if she's got that and what what special
food should she be eating to help
rebuild her brain
Eggs three twice a day don't they
contain cholesterol
cholesterol is good didn't you know
cholesterol makes up 25 of the brain
weight and 25 percent of the of the
weight of the spinal cord the myelin in
the brain the white matter the brain
when it slowly starts going away you get
Tremors and it could be called
Parkinson's disease it could be called
Ms it could be called Guillain-Barre
syndrome depending on what locations
these tremors are in
but it's all the same and um yeah I'd go
with her body weight she could take
three eggs twice a day with soft yolks
hard-boiled eggs won't count they won't
work uh you need soft scrambled in
butter or sauce scrambled or soft
poached in butter
um I had three soft post days this
morning I'll have three soft scrambled
eggs at dinner tonight and butter it's
one of those things where uh it's
imperative to get that cholesterol
because again 25 of your brain weight 25
of your spinal cord weight is
cholesterol cholesterol makes up 95 of
the female hormones and 95 of the male
hormones
awesome
okay
okay thank you so very much
medical doctors are buying all the eggs
and they're telling other people not to
eat eggs and the doctors are buying all
the eggs for themselves
foreign
so thank you so much Aziz for coming on
with that question and I would like to
just kind of expound on eggs a little
bit now Dr Wallach says soft poach soft
scrambled soft boiled and that soft part
is making sure that the yolk stays soft
you want the white to become opaque but
you want the yolk itself to still not be
overcooked because overcooking is kills
the cholesterol
so we want that good cholesterol to
protect our brain to protect our nerves
to pre to to give us what our body needs
so that we can reduce cognitive and
um neurological type conditions because
that cholesterol is what's protecting
our brain and what's protecting the
nerves
so with soft scrambled you want your
eggs to be wet
a wet scramble
okay and uh the way I do it is I cook
um I I use electricity right now and
it's on three I get my pan warm I just
warm enough that my butter gets melted
once my butter is melted but not bubbly
we don't want to burn the butter we want
to make sure that we keep that butter
and content and check also because it's
full of vitamin A which is so important
for the eyes
once that's warm then you pour your
scrambled egg mix in there and
continually use a spatula to stir it
around so that it's not getting too dry
not getting too cooked and then once it
starts to thicken pour it into a little
cup and then you can use a spoon or you
can drink it and don't forget to put
your Himalayan salt mixture in there as
well and salt to taste so seasoned salt
yes from our saber Foods line
um where
I think the creamy Dill right now is my
favorite seasoning femi Dill the
guacamole mix the taco seasoning the
pasta okay I have too many favorites and
I love to cook so there we go well let's
go to the next hand that is up Dr
Wallach and Susan
go ahead and unmute yourself
hi doc Wallach um you're making me
hungry Becca
come on over my friend let's eat
good morning I'm so happy to be here and
I want to just thank you so much for
what you've done for my life personally
I'm 78 and
um I'm just I feel better and happier
and so I'm a distributor and I have two
clients and I have two questions they
couldn't come on today and one is about
a dog and she's about eight years old
and I got her onto arthrodex right away
because she was doing some kind of
behavior like
um
aggressiveness and she wasn't aggressive
yes that's it and I use it for my cat
too and she's just wonderful and um but
this dog had bitten the clothes of a
housekeeper so the housekeeper quit and
then the arthroducts came in and
everything calmed down just beautifully
and she called me and said she was
really happy they were having a great
time but last week they she was gently
petting the dog it weighs about uh it's
eight years old it's a little dog I'm
sorry I don't know the breed but it
bitter and it growling she said a devil
like flesh and the trainer said to have
it's a hymn actually tested for complete
thyroid blood panel
um so I'm wondering if you have any
suggestions for this little dog that
just all of a sudden in a second being
petted uh sitting by her side is it a
long-haired dog or short hair I believe
it's short-haired okay
um yeah again you want to go with the
arthrodex and the Orthodox to the dog
food make sure it's a canned dog food
with no no gluten in it
yes she's aware of no she's known gluten
herself okay good and then you need to
do the arthrodex just one scoop for 20
pounds of body weight so if the dog
weighs six eight ten pounds I go with a
half a scoop if the dog weighs 12-15
pounds I would go with a full scoop of
the arthrodex
and
um I I you know have enough of these
Orthodox cans here if there's grocery
stores don't have enough food to supply
my family for the next month guess what
we're eating Orthodox okay
because it is so good I mean you look at
the ingredients in there yeah okay the
ingredients in there are Fit For A King
Fantastic ingredients are really really
really high-end ingredients and so uh I
keep eyeing the dogs supply of arthrodex
they're gonna have to compete with me
is there anything that might help solve
the the sudden flash of anger and that's
what she was worried about yeah well
these those sort of behavior things are
caused by nutritional deficiencies okay
now you might also want to throw in the
synaptive
okay okay put in say one or two of those
synaptive in the dog's food
okay
I would also saw scrambled or soft
poached 1A if the dog only weighs six
eight ten pounds some scramble one egg
and mix it in with the food
okay
cholesterol into that brain
okay excellent now there is a gluten a
non let's see I
a person that eats gluten in the
household would that affect the dog as
well
yeah especially the dog jumps up on on
their lap and licks her face and you
know is laying on their clothes and
their clothes are saturated with sweat
and gluten and yeah
thank you I have one other question I
have a client that has a um a three and
a half year old child she's 32 pounds 41
inches tall she has a cleft palate and
she was quote tongue-tied
um and they didn't Discover it because
it was what they call a sub palate and I
think I don't understand it but it was
not seen and so she didn't speak well at
all and all of her speeching her
speaking was underage for all of the
tests they gave her then they discovered
the sub palate
um and they did surgery when she was I
forget how old
um on the Tongue Tied but they really
didn't address the quest palette she was
vegan for one and a half years of her
life because her mother is a vegan chef
and then the mother decided to give her
meat at one and a half years is there
anything that can be done for the sub
palette
okay well you have to appreciate
that that was a birth defect because
mama was missing nutrients early in
pregnancy when the baby went from a flat
disc into a tube right
okay okay there's a problem there
and it may not be the only location
where there's a problem
at any rate she could have also the baby
could have also had osteoporosis of the
skull squeezing the ninth cranial nerve
which will cause the glossopharyngeal
nerve which could cause problem with the
tongue and the palate and swallowing and
voice and all that kind of stuff okay so
there's those issues
and so
um basically
this child uh needs to get our kids tidy
yeah you can have one meal a day a kid's
toddy kitties add the Cherry mens to it
okay
um it's like one ounce for a hundred
pounds since this kid weighs only 30
something pounds so is that correct how
much does a child weigh uh 32 pounds
okay 32 pounds okay kid weighs 32 pounds
um and then um let's see here
oh yeah I see my My Scene here I got it
mixed up in my line of callers here okay
32 pounds
um she needs to uh uh also be taking
the
[Music]
um
uh let's see here I would go
with the egg she needs
um one egg stamps soft scrambled every
day in butter
she needs the synaptive and her take the
synaptive go ahead and take two of those
twice a day it'll be two vowels a month
for the synaptive and then she also
needs the I would go with the memory FX
you could take two of those twice a day
anything else
31 pounds
32 pounds
32 pounds two twice a day mm-hmm
yep
okay so doctor I've got a big clinical
defect here so okay so I would also
recommend the the kids sprinkles because
that's going to give the the prebiotics
and probiotics to help keep a digestive
system happy so there's balance and
food's being broken down to allow better
digestion
very good thank you thank you Dr Wallach
God bless publish every couple of weeks
because sometimes these things turn
around very quickly call us every couple
of weeks and just bring us up to date
will you please okay thank you I'll get
her on these products if I can right
away thank you
thank you Susan
all right Dr Wallach
lots of information going on today that
and stuff that we don't cover every day
so I love that
let's go to an email that I received
okay and this is a a dog six years old
and has stage four kidney failure
um does not give the weight
unfortunately but let's go say it's a
smaller dog or mid-sized dog 30 pounds
Dr Wallach okay what would you recommend
supplement wise to help prolong her
lifespan or have the option to
okay well kidney failure in dogs the
same thing as kidney failure in humans
and so basically what we need to do is
um get the dog on a good brand of of a
dog food with no gluten in it right
and they say the dog weighs what again
we don't know let's go by let's do 30
pounds okay let's do 30 pounds okay so
I'd go with two scoops of the arthro
decks two scoops of arthritax in the dog
food good brand of canned dog food no
gluten and then I would also give the
dog two twice a day or if they only feed
the dog once a day give it to three
three of the ultimate daily classic
towels to support healthy blood flow
through the brain arteries with heart
arteries in the kidney arteries and
supporting healthy blood pressure
okay and that will deal with the kidneys
all right thank you so much what about
essential fatty acids Dr Wallach
hmm
inside the arthronex there we go
that's why we love arthrodex okay
and it is beef flavored I like beef well
it's not only beef flavored it has beef
in it
well that's not here on our cabinets so
that if they they're not selling food or
it gets you know to 25 for a dozen eggs
or something like that we'll be eating
the arthro decks the dog's just gonna
have to sit there and look
I'm gonna think I'm gonna stock up on on
food
just I'll have that as a backup but I
think I'm going to stock up on food
personally
let's go to the next town that is up Dr
Wallach and
my beautiful co-host Ruth Ellen
you're on live with ask
that line
hello
um I have a human question Donna
um one of my customers in a distributor
has sent a message that and she is
79 years old
she weighs 175 pounds
and she's five foot four and a half
inches
and she says hi Ruth Ellen I won't be
able to be on the zoo today is it
possible to ask doc a question
I've been diagnosed with possible hyper
tropic
hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy and would like to know
what's the secret sauce
is to address this issue in addition to
the protocol that she uses that he
suggested okay this is very very easy
now this is the disease that kills 500
to a thousand young athletes in America
every year this is a disease
that causes
cinnamon death syndrome
okay it's a simple nutritional
deficiency and I'm not going to tell you
what the secret sauce is you can read it
in the book okay rare Earth's been cures
you can read it in book uh epigenetics
you can read it in the book Dead Doctors
Don't Lie I'm not going to tell you
which nutrient it is because I don't
want somebody running the store and
buying one nutrient they take it and
then they die
because they didn't have the other 89
okay so yeah basically I want heard
175 pounds get rid of all the bad foods
no fried foods no processed Meats no
oils no glutens no wheat no butter Rhino
notes no sugar no carbon or drinks
um even though that one's got to go and
then 175 pounds already have two healthy
brain and heart packs for months two
Health abandoned heart patch a month to
full dose of everything twice a day okay
and then I wanted to have two bottles a
month of the MSM so you can take three
breakfast treat Lemon Street dinner time
and then I wanted to have one scoop of
the collagen peptides at breakfast and
dinner I want her to have the
um let's see here
uh
oh I also wanted to have the ultimate
daily classic tab let's take three of
those I had her take three times a day
three at breakfast sweet lunch at dinner
time it'll be three bottles a month
because they're small bottles and the
older daily classic tablets are going to
support healthy blood flow to block your
arteries in the brain the heart the
kidneys everywhere else and and legs and
so forth and
but she's got to be gluten-free and
buckwheat free
so that she does not block absorption of
nutrients she's got to be
free of um
carbonation even the dot drinks that are
carbonated because she won't be able to
absorb minerals
and so this is easily reversible it's
very simple nutritional deficiency
disease is not genetic it's not
autoimmune it's we deal with this all
the time
it's a very common disease to remember
mineral nutrients do not occur in a
uniform blanket around the crust of the
earth they occur in veins like gold and
silver so she's living in a place where
she's you know eating from the local
grocery stores and the farm markets and
stuff like that and they don't have
these nutrients in the soil they're the
farmers know this so they put these
nutrients in the feed they're giving
their livestock but they don't put it
into the soil in their fields and so the
food that they're selling in the market
doesn't have those nutrients in it
so everybody's especially in those areas
responsible just remember
1936 U.S Senate document 264 came out
and said there's no longer sufficient
minerals in American Farm stalls to
support human life
plants do not make minerals so I'm
giving that much of a hint it's a
mineral okay but I don't like it I used
to tell people they said which one isn't
I would tell them and then I would call
the Family maybe six months I said well
how's Frank doing oh he did what you
told me took that mineral and three
months later he died
what that secret sauce was they need all
90. yes
yes we do all 90
and fortunately there's blooming
minerals that we can put in the soil in
our Gardens and that will give it to us
absolutely it takes the place of the
wood ashes and coal ashes we used to put
in the gardens before
1882 when we went to electricity and
actually the book that tells the whole
story if people want the facts then go
to Hell's Kitchen it tells about the
transition where for thousands and
thousands and thousands of years we were
using wood ashes and coal ashes as
fertilizer and in our food as a spice
and then at three o'clock in the
afternoon Monday September 4th 1882 on
Pearl Street in New York City in the
bluff where we're looking construction
at Brooklyn Bridge Town assassin pulled
the switch we went to electricity and
now our health trouble started
you'll sit down thank you so much Dr
Wallach you bet
all right thank you Ruth Ellen
Dr Wallach I I just want to remind
everybody that if you are on with us or
watching the replay get back with the
person that shared this program with you
thank them for the information that you
have been able to hear in this program
that is empowering these are things that
you can take upon yourself things that
you can remove from your diet from the
diet of your
pets make smarter choices as to what you
and your pets are eating and the
products that you're using in your
environment because
we have a lot of choice when it comes to
those things we need to
use those choices
go to asks.live.com and you can find the
replay of this program to share with
others and all of our replays are there
as well with short
um kind of summaries of what the program
is about our co-host jonty mccollier who
is actually also our webmaster does a
fabulous job getting these posted and if
you want a reminder
and an invitation to our future
calls that happen every Friday 8 A.M to
10 a.m Pacific time make sure that you
sign up for our newsletter
and you will get in your email delivered
to you your personal invitation with
link all you have to do is click and
here you are
so Dr Wallach let's go ahead and go to
another email that came in and uh
Seville is writing in says I have a
three-year-old female cat
who began losing her appetite
and she now has to be forced fed every
hour or so day and night
she's becoming progressively light and
scrawny her blood and stool tests are
all negative
but bacteria was found in her urine
x-rays yep arthrodex good for cats and
dogs
they they say that the x-rays turned out
positive for hip dysplasia
osteoarthritis and has been prescribed
anti-inflammatories
that is crazy
anti-inflammatories for nutritional
deficiency
and you think about that okay and so
this cat she weighed what five six
pounds
probably well she's lost her appetite
she's losing weight so she might even be
less than that okay so she needs the
Arthur to actually be added to a canned
dog food excuse me canned cat food
canned cat food okay cheese arthroducts
there's one scoop for 20 pounds of body
weight but I'd go heavy here I'd feed
that cat two three meals a day and you
know put like a a third of a scoop in
each of the three meals and then also uh
I would give that cat again canned dog
food not I keep saying dog food canned
cat food and then has fish in it as
opposed to dry cat food don't do that go
with a canned cat food with a fish in it
okay and for a treat doesn't hurt to get
like uh salmon fillet or Cod fillet or
tuna fillet or something like that okay
kind of stimulate that cat and
that's kind of where I would go
and um it's imperative that there's no
gluten in that cat food no gluten to
maximize absorption
and
um it's one of those things where if
they're given that cat table straps it
could be cross-contaminated with gluten
that way and there's something you know
and they can't find anything on tests
and everything
but the cat is losing weight and so
forth and not eating there's something
going on metabolically or something like
that and so let's the cat's gonna love
this arthrodex because it does have red
meat in it okay and that's why I'm
saving a lot for me so if they can't
sell food at the grocery store I'm
eating orthodox
that she has gingivitis and has
undergone teeth extractions
osteoporosis let's go
mineral deficiencies yes and the vet
wants her to be tested for
toxoplasmosis
the cat has a hip problem too right
yeah
okay so it doesn't hurt also uh to be
the the good brand to cat food will have
plenty of minerals in it the arthrodex
has plenty of minerals in it but it
wouldn't hurt to put
um like an ounce of our plant-derived
colloidal minerals into the water bowl
okay and then you fill it halfway with
water and an ounce of the plant derived
colloidal minerals liquid in there and
Stir It Up really good so even if that
cat just drinks a couple of swallows of
waters getting those minerals
and Dr Wallach for for animals that are
not eating and drinking very well I love
to put our plant derived minerals in a
spray bottle and spray their bellies
and have that in the skin they'll absorb
through the skin absolutely and you can
even open up their mouths and spray it
into their mouth
and then it's absorbing in through the
tissue within their mouths into their
bloodstream
so because I've had people tell me well
they won't eat they won't drink okay
let's look for the solution that's the
problem but there's solutions to every
single problem and it's a simple
solution with the plant dried minerals
which is the correct solution
which is the correct solution yeah
because it's addressing the the
underlying cause
so that's awesome well
everybody if you've got a question don't
hesitate don't be shy raise your hand we
have just a couple more men that's here
on ask that live and I do have another
question for Dr Wallach because I get a
lot of questions in regards to pets
and
it looks like Gail has a four-year-old
Yorkshire Terrier so a little dog
well depending off if it's a teacup a
miniature or a standard
um she's been diagnosed with severe
collapsing trachea
she wants to know what is a treatment
for this are there any products that
will Aid in the prevention of continued
deterioration of her trachea cartilage
again make sure the dog is getting that
um plants arrive minerals either put it
in the water but also you can rub it on
the belly
um don't forget the arthrodex is one
scoop for 20 pounds of body weight and
if this dog
um weighs what
um she doesn't give a weight so
depending on which there's one scoop for
20 pounds of body weight okay of the
arthrodex don't forget to put an ounce
of the plant derived colloidal minerals
into the water dish okay and
um rub some on the belly you put you
know a cotton ball lay the dog on your
lap on its back and rub the throttle
minerals into the belly I'll tell you a
quick story about the Pastor Mike
Freeman up in Baltimore Maryland was
Linda Tyler and
he was in a coma for six months this is
a this is a pasture
in a coma and the the doctors called his
wife and called Linda and said hey this
guy's got less than two days to live if
you want to maybe remotely he can hear
you we don't know but you better come
say goodbye now because you won't see
him alive after two or three days
so she calls me and I said well does he
have a G2 we can pour the minerals down
his stomach no no okay we just
um take the plant Metals rub them on his
chest his belly but on his back between
his shoulder blades and his low back
and you know put a half a cup three
times a day
three days time he wakes up shaves goes
back to work at the church and he makes
us a set a CD and a DVD called Praise
the Lord and pass the 90.
and we're actually adding to that we're
going to add to that praise the Lord
praise the Lord in Panasonic
um we were doing a bunch of testimonies
we're going to add to that because
here's his Pastor ten years ago we had
three days to live two days to live one
day to live whatever it was because he
had these mineral deficiencies and he
was able to absorb them through his skin
on his chest and his belly and his back
and it brought him back and here we are
I don't know 10 years later and he's
perfectly normal
praise the Lord and pass to 90. that's
available
yeah it and it's incredible Dr Wall like
what the body can do when it's given the
raw ingredients that it was designed to
have
absolutely
and it's simple
folks think well that's not possible
well I'm here to say it's very possible
I no longer have 17 different conditions
on Pharmaceuticals
to even address the side effects of a
pharmaceutical
and I have more energy
I feel younger I'm told I look younger
than I ever have
and I love it I'm looking forward to
getting old Dr Wallen
well we're going to get all together
because I'm going for you know
Methuselah went to 969 why can't we go
to a thousand
okay so there's nothing like shooting
for the moon and Landing amongst the
Stars you're gonna win right that's
correct
all right well I will be right there
with you and I know many of us will be
as we take our 90 our 90 essential
nutrients which are only available
through the company that you founded
even though you no longer receive a
paycheck from them you are here
just promoting what the body needs
and the formulas that you've created
plus there's been companies that have
created some good formulas that
come youngevity thought were
outstanding enough to be included in the
youngevity family of products including
the arthritax
so and so let's talk a little bit in
addition to the arthritis because
artherdex comes from our fertel's only
line they also have bark bites the bark
bites are nice little cookies treats for
your for your dogs
there's some crack
it's I can't remember the whole name of
it
um but I had somebody so excited to see
that we carried it not realizing and it
was a youngevity product because she was
a dog trainer or is a dog trainer and
it's tiny little squares and she uses
those as the treats
for training the dogs when she's working
with dogs now those are the those are
those are about three inches long
they're good size
and I break them up
yeah little bones like little dog bones
okay but they don't have the gluten they
don't have the barley the rice the wheat
the oats they're full of nutrition
they've got the minerals in them but we
no buckwheat that's right
um and so you can feel good about what
you're giving your pet when it comes to
their treats as well and as
a fur baby mama
um and Nana I have lots of her baby
grandbabies
um
it just it just makes you feel good that
you're contributing to life and not
something that's destroying
any cellular growth within a body
I
have to ask you this for all my
listeners out there because this is a
huge problem okay no pun intended
how much weight have you lost
I lost
I've lost 105 pounds Dr Wally okay and
how long a time did it take you to do
that on our program
oh goodness I've been with youngevity
seven years now and I was not
intentionally trying to lose weight I
was so sick and miserable that I just
wanted relief to get through the day
and the weight loss was just a bonus
but most of my weight loss happened
within a two and a half three year
period
without
extensive exercise
I was just making sure I was given my
body what it needed so it could let go
of what it didn't because it thought it
was starving yeah and so you had Pica
you were eating and eating and eating
trying to find what it is your body was
missing it was nutrition and so this is
why most people have a weight challenge
is they're minimally deficient if they
get in our program they'll lose a half a
pound of two pounds a day so we're very
very proud of you and thank you it's an
honor to be working with you because you
are not shy about sharing your your
problem and your great results or so
very proud of you thank you so much
oh you're very welcome yeah I'm I I'm an
open book when it comes to
not wanting to hide my my story when
somebody asks me
so it's I've been blessed Dr Wallach
finding you
finding the products I'm getting to know
more about the products
which
I am
so before I found you Dr Wallach uh I
was an herbalist creating herbal
tinctures
for a functional medicine practitioner
helping a lot of people
but I couldn't help myself
because it was severe severe severe
osteoporosis of the skull
which yes those herbs have some minerals
but they don't have the 90 essential
nutrients
and were you eating
well of course I was don't you know
whole grains are good for you I was even
grinding my own wheat making my own
bread making my own cinnamon rolls using
raw cane sugar
who told Americans eat whole grains
our government
and the doctors
medical doctors
okay when they they were complaining
that they you know that they were
gaining weight and so forth so stop
eating uh animal fat
stop eating animal fat and eat whole
grains and then obesity shot off the
roof as soon as they began people began
to listen to doctors and ate more whole
grains and gave up eating animal fat
animal fat is good as long as you don't
burn it
that's it I don't think anything burnt
really tastes good anyways
and I've learned to not burn water so
that's a plus
don't burn water and you know don't eat
fried don't eat fried water
yeah and if you burn something folks
don't eat it anyways you're worth just
tossing it out don't give it to the dog
don't give it to the cat toss it out
start over well if it's something
expensive it'd be really really
heartbroken to throw away you donate to
your doctor
all right
well I'm not going to donate it to my
doctor because my doctor on my screen is
right next to me and I'm trying to keep
him around for a while for all of us to
be able to glean from his knowledge and
research as
just an amazing
veterinarian pathologist
naturopath doctor
it's you have all of all of these
credentials Dr Wallach that are not just
papers they're things that you have dug
into you've put your brain into your
hands into and have been very
instrumental in making sure that your
research your information
is published and available for us
as individuals
to be able to get that information as
well
and I know I appreciate it jonty
appreciates it nasima appreciates it
Ruth Ellen appreciates it not only for
what has done for us physically and our
families
but you know the paycheck helps too
and the fact that we're doing it for a
good cause which what's a better cause
than helping your community
yes we do things because it's coming
from the heart but when even our
coming from the heart that Financial
return
is is helpful and keeps us going
whenever
we have to pay the bills
so it's all in your head I kind of like
that look Dr Wallach well you did the CD
along with me that's the CD is you and
me together and the CD goes along with
the book
it's all in your head
yep absolutely and you've added some
more
um different conditions through your
research that you have found that are
also associated with osteoporosis of the
head
so a skull rather so
everybody if you've got a whole bunch of
unexplained things going on your doctors
can't tell you what's going on and they
keep throwing
pills at you let's throw some natural
stuff natural formal pills at you and
powders and let's give the body what it
needs to not just survive
but thrive
you have been watching ask that live
a sub program of ask doc live sponsored
by askdoglive.com
we invite you to get back with the
person that shared this program with you
and thank them for the information that
you learned today and how you too can
get products that will be beneficial in
providing you the 90 for life way my
name is Becca Dukes on behalf of my
great team with me today Jonathan
McCauley Ruth Ellen Sanchez nasima Omar
and Dr Joel Wallach
have a fabulous day bye for now bye bye
we love you
mwah love you all
bye bye everybody